Have you noticed?
Here on the internet,
Bernie Sanders is
everywhere!
Wall Street
and Wall Street
This matters because
in the betting for who will be the next president,
Donald Trump the incumbent leads but,
among Democrats,
Senator Sanders is among the top four.
Thank you all very much.
Let's go forward together!
And most people don't know that Sanders
has quietly built a digital media empire.
That means he's in competition with me,
and he's winning!
His videos come out every few hours
and they've been viewed
almost a billion times.
You are talking about oligarchy.
Many of his videos
are just him ranting
about how Republican ideas hurt people.
Here he claims that the
repeal of Obamacare will kill Americans.
Tens of thousands of them
will die.
He ignores the thousands who may live
if the economy is allowed to grow.
Other Sanders videos
are edited, produced, propaganda pieces.
Here, Sanders staff runs a Trump speech
where Trump quotes a song
about a woman who takes a snake into her home
and the snake then bites her.
Trump uses it to take
an unfair, mean-spirited swipe against immigrants,
while arguing for tighter immigration controls.
Sanders has every right to criticize that,
but then he runs a clip suggesting
that the president calls all minority immigrants
animals.
But the video never mentions
that Trump's animal comment
was about the MS-13 gang.
Another consistent theme in Sanders videos
is that lots of people on the right are
horrible, greedy people
who scheme to get more money,
in this case by
abolishing the estate tax.
They claim repeal will save Trump
four billion dollars.
He doesn't mention that the estate tax
taxes money that was already taxed,
it's double taxation.
He could still argue against repeal, but
he ought to be fair.
Many Sanders videos demand that he make college free
because it's just too expensive.
His staff interviews themselves.
Again, there's no mention of how existing
tuition subsidies already increased
the price of tuition.
And there's not a peep about how
his own wife's shady financial dealings
bankrupted a college.
It's just
government must pay more.
Government should take responsibility
for your health care too,
says this video
which describes MSNBC anchor Ali Velshi
as a Canadian capitalist.
This is billed as a debate but
Republican Jim Jordan hardly gets to say anything.
It's easy to win an argument
if you never let the other guy speak.
Almost all new income and wealth is going to
the top one percent.
Probably the biggest theme in Bernie videos
is income inequality,
which Bernie says:
is not only immoral,
it is causing massive suffering.
But he's just wrong.
The wealth gap doesn't cause suffering.
Yes, rich people got richer,
but the poor and middle class got richer too.
Bernie never says that.
And the poor are getting poorer.
Sanders posts a new, economically ignorant video
most every day.
He says it would be easy
to have free health care, free college,
a living wage.
How will it be paid for?
Simple, raise taxes.
Sanders says the responsible rich
want to pay more.
So pay more!
No one's stopping you.
Or give to charity.
Charities will spend your money
better than government will.
Socialists think government's the solution
to every problem
and they pretend that what government provides is free.
Free education.
Universal health care.
A living wage.
Bernie's videos would be just a joke
except
millions of people watch
and lots believe the nonsense he preaches.
We look at these figures and we say,
Oh unemployment is low, everything is
fine, right?
Well unemployment is low
because everyone has two jobs.
What?
That's not how unemployment works.
I don't know if she learned that from Bernie, but
Senator Sanders is the king
of economic ignorance.
The top 10 percent
gets it all.
Gets it all!
And a billion people watch.
You should know about that.
We'll watch
so you don't have to.